Je vais vous présenter trois de mes inventions
qui peuvent concerner de dix à cent millions de personnes,
et que nous espérons se voir réaliser.
Dans le film précédent, nous avons vu des réalisations plus anciennes
comme les stents et les pompes à insuline pour les diabétiques.
Je voudrais parler rapidement de trois nouvelles inventions
qui vont changer la vie de beaucoup de personnes.
A l'heure actuelle, il se passe en moyenne trois heures
entre le moment où le patient a les premiers symptômes d'une crise cardiaque,
et celui où il arrive aux urgences.
Et pour les gens avec une ischémie silencieuse --
ce qui, en langage courant, veut dire qu'ils n'ont aucun symptôme --
il se passe encore plus de temps avant qu'ils n'arrivent à l'hôpital.
L'infarctus aigu du myocarde,
expression savante des médecins leur permettant de vous faire payer plus cher --
(Rires)
-- désigne la crise cardiaque. Elle touche annuellement 1,2 millions d'Américains.
Mortalité : 300.000 personnes par an.
La moitié d'entre eux, 600.000, a des dégâts permanents au cœur
qui provoqueront ultérieurement des problèmes graves.
Donc, 900.000 sont, soit décédées,
soit elles ont des dégâts importants au cœur.
Les symptômes sont souvent niés par le patient, surtout nous les hommes
car nous sommes très courageux. Nous sommes très courageux.
et nous ne voulons pas admettre qu'on a un mal de chien à la poitrine.
Donc, à peu près 25 pourcents des patients n'ont jamais de symptômes.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour eux ? Comment peut-on sauver leur vie ?
C'est particulièrement vrai pour les diabétiques et les femmes plus âgées.
Que faut-il pour être prévenu le plus tôt possible d'une crise cardiaque ?
Un moyen de déterminer s'il y a un blocage complet de l'artère coronaire ?
Ceci, mesdames et messieurs, est une crise cardiaque.
Le moyen consiste à remarquer quelque chose d'un peu technique,
L'élevation du segment ST de l'électrocardiogramme.
En langage courant, cela signifie que
s'il y a un signal électrique dans le cœur et qu'une partie de l'ECG --
qu'on appelle le segment ST -- s'élève,
c'est un signe sûr de crise cardiaque.
Et si l'on avait un ordinateur à l'intérieur d'une personne à risque,
on pourrait savoir, avant même l'apparition des symptômes,
qu'ils sont en train d'avoir une crise cardiaque et ainsi sauver leur vie.
Le médecin peut programmer un niveau d'augmentation de la tension ST
qui va activer une alarme,
une vibration comme votre téléphone portable mais tout près de votre clavicule.
Et quand elle se met à sonner, vous avez intérêt à faire quelque chose,
car si vous voulez vivre, vous avez besoin de soins médicaux.
Nous devons tester ces équipements
parce que l'Administration ne nous laissera pas les utiliser tels quels sur des gens
sans que nous ne les testions,
et le meilleur système pour les tester, ce sont les cochons.
Avec le cochon, nous avons essayé des électrodes externes sur la peau,
comme on voit dans une salle d'urgences,
et je vais vous montrer pourquoi cela ne marche pas très bien.
On place un fil, un conducteur, dans le ventricule droit à l'intérieur du cœur,
qui fournit l'électrocardiogramme, qui est le signal électrique venant du cœur.
Avec le cochon, au départ,
voici le signal avant que l'on ne bloque l'artère pour simuler une crise cardiaque.
Après 43 secondes, même un expert ne voit aucune différence,
et après trois minutes,
si vous l'avez vraiment étudié, vous devriez voir une différence.
Mais qu'est-il arrivé à l'électrocardiogramme quand on examine le cœur du cochon ?
Il y a la ligne de départ -- en premier lieu, un signal bien plus fort et plus fiable.
Ensuite, je parie que même vous qui n'êtes pas formés, pouvez voir la différence,
et l'on voit ici une élévation du segment ST directement après cette ligne raide
Voyez la différence là -- ce n'est pas difficile,
même un non-initié peut voir la différence,
et les ordinateurs peuvent être programmés pour le détecter facilement.
Maintenant, regardez ceci après trois minutes.
Nous voyons que le signal qui est en fait dans le cœur,
nous pouvons l'exploiter pour dire aux gens qu'ils vont avoir une crise cardiaque
même avant les symptômes et ainsi sauver leur vie.
Alors, on l'a essayé avec mon fils, le docteur Tim Fischell,
on a essayé avec des patients à qui on devait poser un stent.
Il a gardé le ballon gonflé pour bloquer l'artère,
pour simuler un blocage qui est, en fait, une crise cardiaque.
Et il n'est pas difficile de voir que la ligne de départ
est la première figure en haut à gauche.
A côté, après 30 secondes, vous voyez cette élévation ici,
et puis cette élévation-ci -- c'est l'élévation ST.
Et si nous avions un ordinateur qui pouvait le détecter,
nous pourrions vous dire que vous êtes déjà en train d'avoir une crise cardiaque
cela pourrait sauver votre vie et prévenir une insuffisance cardiaque.
Et il l'a refait. Nous avons rempli le ballon quelques minutes plus tard
et vous voyez ici, même après 10 secondes, une grande élévation dans cette partie,
et si l'on avait un ordinateur dans votre poitrine comme un pacemaker,
avec un fil dans votre coeur comme un pacemaker.
Et les ordinateurs ne dorment pas.
Nous avons une petite batterie et avec cette petite batterie
cet ordinateur va fonctionner cinq années sans besoin de remplacement.
A quoi ressemble le système ?
Bien, à gauche il y a l'équipement médical implantable IMD,
et ce soir, dans la tente, vous pouvez le voir -- ils l'ont exposé.
C'est à peu près grand comme ceci, la dimension d'un pacemaker.
C'est implanté avec des techniques conventionnelles.
Et le dispositif extérieur EXD peut se poser sur votre table de nuit.
Il vous réveillera et vous dira d'aller faire la queue aux urgences
quand cela se déclenche, et si vous ne le faites pas, vous êtes dans la merde.
Et finalement, un programmateur va définir le niveau de stimulation,
qui est le niveau qui indiquera que vous avez une crise cardiaque.
L'Administration dit, OK, testez ce dispositif implanté dans un animal,
et nous avons choisi le cochon, donc, il fallait que le cochon ait une crise cardiaque.
Et quand vous allez à la ferme, il est difficile de provoquer une crisa cardiaque chez un cochon,
mais nous sommes des experts en stents.
Ce soir, vous allez voir quelques uns des stents que nous avons conçus.
Nous avons décidé de mettre un stent,
mais nous n'allons pas mettre un stent destiné aux êtres humains.
Nous allons mettre un stent en cuivre,
et ce stent en cuivre va éroder l'artère et provoquer une crise cardiaque.
Ce n'est pas très sympa mais, après tout, on devait trouver une solution.
Donc, on a mis deux stents en cuivre dans l'artère de ce cochon,
et laissez-moi vous montrer le résultat qui est très satisfaisant
particulièrement pour les personnes qui ont des maladies vasculaires.
Et voilà, jeudi matin, on a arrêté de soigner le cochon
et voici l'électrocardiogramme, le signal en provenance du cœur du cochon
émis par radio télémétrie.
Puis vendredi à 06h43, il commença à montrer des signes,
puis on a fait courir le cochon --
Je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails.
Mais regardez ce qui est arrivé à 10h06 quand on a arrêté les médicaments
qui le prémunissaient d'une crise cardiaque.
Vous êtes tous experts en élévation ST maintenant. Vous la voyez ici ?
Vous pouvez la voir sur cette image après le pic QRS, vous voyez l'élévation ST ?
Ce cochon, à 10h06, était en train d'avoir une crise cardiaque.
Qu'arrive-t-il après que vous ayez une crise cardiaque, ce blocage ?
Votre rythme cardiaque devient irrégulier et c'est ce qui est arrivé 45 minutes plus tard.
Puis, fibrillation ventriculaire, le cœur tremble au lieu de battre,
ceci est juste avant la mort du cochon et puis, le cochon est mort, le signal s'est arrêté.
Mais nous avions environ une heure pendant laquelle on aurait pu sauver la vie du cochon.
Mais, à cause de l'Administration, on n'a pas sauvé la vie du cochon.
parce qu'on est obligé de faire ceci pour sauver les humains.
Mais quand il s'agit de la santé des humains, on peut sauver leur vie.
Nous pouvons sauver la vie de ceux qui présentent un risque élevé de crise cardiaque.
Quel est le symptôme d'un infarctus du myocarde, une crise cardiaque, aujourd'hui ?
Vous éprouvez une douleur dans la poitrine ou une indigestion.
Ce n'est pas si grave que ça, vous décidez de ne rien faire.
Plusieurs heures passent et ça empire, et même un homme s'en rendra compte.
Finalement, vous allez aux urgences.
Vous attendez pendant que les brûlés et autres patients critiques sont traités,
parce que 75 pourcents des patients qui vont aux urgences avec des douleurs de poitrine,
n'ont pas d'infarctus, donc vous n'êtes pas pris très au sérieux.
Finalement, ils vous examinent. Cela prend encore plus de temps
de faire un électrocardiogramme et d'établir un diagnostic,
et ce n'est pas facile à faire car ils n'ont pas les données de base,
que l'ordinateur qu'on a mis en vous dispose.
Finalement, si vous avez de la chance, vous êtes traités trois ou quatre heures après l'incident,
mais le muscle cardiaque est mort.
Et ça, c'est le cas typique. Dans le monde civilisé. Pas en Afrique --
C'est le cas typique dans le monde civilisé d'aujourd'hui.
Alors, on a développé le Système de l'Ange Gardien Médical.
et on a ce dispositif à l'intérieur du patient qu'on appelle l'Ange Gardien Implanté.
Et quand vous avez un blocage, le dispositif s'active
et il envoie une alarme et l'électrocardiogramme vers un équipement externe,
qui récupère votre électrocardiogramme des dernières 24 heures.
ainsi que celui qui a provoqué l'alarme, que vous pouvez emmener aux urgences
pour leur montrer et leur dire "occupez-vous de moi tout de suite".
Puis cela part vers le centre d'opérations,
où ils récupèrent vos données personnelles
qui sont dans un centre quelque part aux Etats-Unis.
Ensuite cela part vers un centre de diagnostic et en moins d'une minute après l'attaque
votre signal apparaît sur l'écran d'un ordinateur
et l'ordinateur analyse le problème.
Et la personne qui est là, un médecin généraliste, vous appelle --
avec un téléphone portable-- et vous dit,
"Mr Smith, vous êtes dans la merde, vous avez un problème.
Nous avons appelé une ambulance. L'ambulance est en route.
Elle va vous emmener et nous allons appeler votre médecin pour lui dire.
Nous allons lui envoyer le diagramme que nous avons et qui montre que vous avez une crise cardiaque,
et nous allons envoyer le diagramme à l'hôpital
et nous le ferons analyser là-bas,
et là, vous serez avec votre médecin
et vous serez pris en charge pour que vous ne mourriez pas d'une crise cardiaque."
C'est la première invention que je voulais vous décrire.
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, je voudrais vous parler de quelque chose d'entièrement différent.
Au début, je ne croyais pas que les migraines soient un gros problème.
parce que je n'avais jamais eu de migraine.
mais j'ai parlé à des gens qui en ont trois ou quatre par semaine,
et leurs vies sont complètement dévastées par ça.
Notre société à un objectif concernant la migraine qui dit
"Prévenir ou améliorer les migraines
par l'utilisation d'une impulsion magnétique sûre et contrôlée
appliquée, en fonction du besoin, par le patient."
Bon, il y a probablement peu de physiciens ici.
Si vous êtes physiciens, vous savez ce qu'est la Loi de Faraday,
qui dit que si vous appliquez une impulsion magnétique à de l'eau salée --
ce qu'est d'ailleurs votre cerveau --
elle va engendrer des courants électriques et ce courant électrique dans le cerveau
va éliminer la migraine.
C'est ce que nous avons découvert.
Voici une représentation de ce que nous faisons.
Les patients qui ont une migraine précédée par une aura migraineuse
ont une bande de neurones excités -- indiqués en rouge --
qui se déplace de trois à cinq millimètres par minute vers le centre du cerveau.
Et quand cela touche le centre du cerveau, cela déclenche la migraine.
Ceci est une migraine précédée par une aura visuelle,
et cette aura visuelle --je vais vous le montrer sur une figure--
c'est comme s'ill y avait des petites lumières dansantes,
qui grossiraient de plus en plus jusqu'à occuper tout votre champ visuel.
Et ce que l'on a essayé, c'est un dispositif appelé le Modèle Cadwell MES10.
Il pèse près de 30 kilos et a un fil d'un diamètre de trois centimètres.
Et voici un patient qui a une aura
et qui a toujours une migraine, forte, après l'aura. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Voici à quoi ressemble à une aura.
C'est comme des lumières qui dansent, montrées ici à gauche et à droite.
Et ceci est une aura complète comme on le voit au-dessus.
Au centre, notre expérimentateur, le neurologue, qui a dit,
"Je vais descendre ceci un peu et je vais effacer la moitié de votre aura."
Et, mon Dieu, le neurologue l'a effacé, c'est l'image au centre,
la moitié de l'aura effacée par une impulsion magnétique brève.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Cela signifie que l'impulsion magnétique a engendré un courant électrique
qui interfère avec l'activité électrique erronée du cerveau.
Et finalement, il dit : "OK, maintenant je vais --"
effacer toute l'aura avec une impulsion magnétique bien localisée.
Quel est le résultat ? Nous avons conçu un dépolarisateur magnétique,
qui ressemble à ceci, que vous pourriez posséder -- une femme, dans son livre de poche,
et quand vous avez une aura, vous pouvez l'essayer et voir que ça marche.
La chose suivante que je veux vous montrer était sur ABC News,
Canal 7, la semaine dernière à New York, aux infos de 11 heures.
Le présentateur : Pour tous ceux qui souffrent de migraines --
et il y a 30 millions d'Américains dans le cas -- ce soir, il y a une solution.
Un témoin, interrogé par Stacy Sager ce soir, avec une petite machine portable
qui efface littéralement vos migraines.
Christina Sidebottom : Bien, ma première réaction était que --
cela ressemblait affreusement à un revolver, et c'était très étrange.
Stacy Sager : Mais pour Christina Sidebottom, cela valait la peine de tout essayer
si cela pouvait arrêter une migraine.
Cela peut paraître un peu bête ou même effrayant de vous promener avec ça dans votre sac,
mais les chercheurs ici dans l'Ohio qui organisent les tests pour cet effaceur de migraines,
disent que c'est scientifiquement sain.
Qu'en réalité, quand une personne quelconque a une migraine,
c'est provoqué par quelque chose de semblable à une impulsion électrique.
L'effaceur créé un champ magnétique qui va contrebalancer ça.
Yousef Mohammed : En d'autres mots, on traite l'électricité par l'électricité,
plutôt que de traiter l'électricité par les produits chimiques que l'on utilise à l'heure actuelle.
SS : Mais est-ce que c'est sans danger d'utiliser ça tous les jours ?
Les experts disent que la recherche dure depuis plus d'une décennie,
et que des études à plus long terme doivent être faites. Christine ne jure que par ça.
CS : C'est la chose la plus merveilleuse pour mes migraines.
SS : les chercheurs espèrent présenter leurs études à l'Administration cet été.
Robert Fischell : Et ça, c'est l'invention pour traiter les migraines.
(Applaudissements)
Vous voyez, le problème est que 30 millions d'Américains ont des migraines,
Et nous avons besoin d'un moyen de traitement, et je crois que nous l'avons maintenant.
C'est le premier dispositif que nous avons fabriqué et je vais vous parler de mon deuxième vœu,
qui a quelque chose à voir avec cela.
La conclusion à ce stade de nos études, dans les trois centres de recherche,
est qu'il y a une amélioration significative dans la douleur quand on l'a utilisé ne fut-ce qu'une fois.
Les migraines les plus sévères répondent mieux quand on l'a utilisé plusieurs fois.
et cette découverte inattendue montre que même les migraines les plus tenaces,
et pas seulement celles avec des auras, sont traitées et disparaissent.
Et les auras peuvent être effacées et la migraine, alors, n'apparaît pas.
Voici l'invention pour traiter la migraine dont nous parlons et sur laquelle nous travaillons.
(Applaudissements)
La troisième et dernière invention a débuté avec une idée.
L'épilepsie est traitée le mieux avec une stimulation électrique "sensible".
pourquoi utilisons-nous -- ajoutons l'expression "foyer épileptogène" ?
Malheureusement, nous autres, techniciens, à l'inverse de M. Bono,
devons utiliser tous ces termes techniques.
Bien, la stimulation électrique "sensible" signifie
que nous détectons, à un endroit de votre cerveau qui est appelé un "foyer épileptogène",
qui est là où se trouve l'épilepsie -- là où la crise d'épilepsie commence.
On détecte là, que cela va arriver,
et on réagit en appliquant de l'énergie électrique en ce point,
qui efface le signal erratique
de telle manière que vous n'éprouvez pas les manifestations d'une migraine.
Nous utilisons la technologie de défibrillation des pacemakers actuels qui est utilisée pour le cœur.
Nous pensions pouvoir l'adapter pour le cerveau.
Le dispositif pourrait être implanté sous le cuir chevelu
pour être totalement invisible et pour éviter les ruptures de fil,
qui arrive si vous l'avez mis dans la poitrine et que vous tournez la tête dans tous les sens.
Monter une société pour produire un neuro-pacemaker pour l'épilepsie,
et toutes les maladies du cerveau, parce que toutes les maladies du cerveau
sont le résultat d'un dysfonctionnement électrique à l'intérieur de celui-ci,
qui provoque la majorité, sinon la totalité, des désordres cérébraux.
Nous avons constitué une société appelée NeuroPace
et nous avons commencé à travailler sur la neuro-stimulation sensible,
et ceci est une figure de ce à quoi ressemble le dispositif,
qui est placé dans la boîte crânienne.
Ceci est probablement une meilleure image.
Ici, nous avons le dispositif que nous avons mis dans une monture.
On pratique une incision dans le cuir chevelu, on l'ouvre, le neurochirurgien a un gabarit,
il le marque et utilise une fraise de dentiste
pour retirer un morceau du crâne qui a exactement les dimensions du dispositif.
Et ce soir, vous pourrez voir ce dispositif dans la tente.
Ensuite nous avons --avec quatre vis, posé la monture,
et nous clipsons le dispositif et nous l'équipons de fils --
celui qui est en vert va vers la surface du cerveau avec des électrodes
jusqu'au foyer épileptogène, l'origine de l'épilepsie,
où l'on détecte le signal électrique
et on a une analyse par ordinateur qui nous dit de répondre avec un certain courant électrique
pour empêcher la manifestation clinique de la crise.
Dans le fil bleu, on a ce qu'on appelle une électrode profonde de cerveau.
Si c'est l'origine de l'épilepsie, on peut la soigner également.
Une solution globale : ceci est le dispositif,
approximativement deux centimètres sur cinq et, assez curieusement,
exactement l'épaisseur de la boîte crânienne.
Les avantages de la neurostimulation sensible :
le dispositif peut détecter et arrêter les crises avant que les symptômes cliniques n'apparaissent,
provoquer une stimulation uniquement en cas de nécessité,
peut-être éteint si les crises disparaissent, cela a des effets secondaires minimum --
de toute évidence, dans tous nos essais cliniques à ce jour,
nous n'avons vu aucun effet secondaire sur la quarantaine de patients dans lesquels il a été implanté --
il est invisible, caché de manière cosmétique,
ainsi, si vous souffrez d'épilepsie et si vous avez le dispositif,
personne ne le saura car ça ne se voit pas.
Et ceci est un électroencéphalogramme,
et à gauche, c'est le signal d'une crise spontanée d'un de nos patients.
Nous avons stimulé et vous voyez cette ligne noire épaisse
et vous voyez que l'électroencéphalogramme retourne à la normale,
ce qui signifie qu'il n'y a pas eu de crise d'épilepsie.
Ceci conclut ma présentation sur l'épilepsie et --
sur la troisième invention que je voulais présenter ici cet après-midi.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai trois vœux. Bien, je ne peux pas grand-chose pour l'Afrique.
Je suis un technicien, je suis dans le gadget médical,
qui est essentiellement hi-tech comme M. Bono l'a dit.
le premier souhait est d'utiliser le neurostimulateur sensible à l'épilepsie,
appelé NSR, pour NeuroStimulateur Réactif --c'est un sigle génial--
pour le traitement d'autres désordres cérébraux.
Si on peut le faire pour l'épilepsie, pourquoi, diable, pas sur autre chose ?
Vous avez vu à quoi ressemblait le dispositif,
que la femme utilisait pour guérir ses migraines ?
Je vous le dis : c'est quelque chose qu'un ingénieur de recherche comme moi bricolerait,
pas réellement un concepteur de bon équipement.
(Rires)
Nous aimerions avoir des gens qui savent vraiment faire ça,
réalisant des études d’ingénierie pour réaliser la conception optimale
pour le dispositif portable qui traite les migraines.
Et certain des sponsors de TED sont de telles organisations.
Puis nous allons mettre au défi les participants de TED
de trouver une manière d'améliorer le système de santé aux Etats-Unis,
où l'on a des problèmes que l'Afrique n'a pas.
Et de réduire les litiges liés aux erreurs médicales --
le litige lié à une erreur médicale n'est pas un problème africain, c'est un problème américain.
(Applaudissements)
Donc, pour revenir rapidement à mon premier vœu --
le cerveau opère par signaux électriques.
Si les signaux électriques provoquent un désordre cérébral,
la stimulation électrique peut surmonter ce désordre en agissant sur les neurones.
En d'autres termes, si vous avez des signaux électriques foireux,
peut-être qu'en mettant dans le cerveau d'autres signaux électriques générés par un ordinateur,
nous pouvons contrer cela.
Un signal dans le cerveau qui déclenche un dysfonctionnement cérébral
peut être détecté pour provoquer une électrosimulation
comme nous le faisons pour l'épilepsie.
Mais même s'il n'y a pas de signal,
l'électrostimulation d'un endroit approprié du cerveau peut arrêter un désordre cérébral.
Considérez le traitement des désordres psychotiques --
et je souhaite que TED y soit engagé --
comme le trouble obsessionnel compulsif
qui, actuellement, n'est pas bien traité avec les médicaments et concerne 5 millions d'Américains.
Et M. Fischer, et son groupe à NeuroPace, et moi-même croyons
que nous pouvons traiter de manière significative les TOC aux Etats-Unis et dans le monde.
Ceci est mon premier vœu.
(Applaudissements)
Le second vœu est, à l'heure actuelle,
les tests cliniques des stimulateurs magnétiques transcraniens --
c'est ce que le sigle SMT signifie, un dispositif qui traite les migraines --
semblent être couronnés de succès.
C'est une bonne nouvelle.
Le dispositif portable actuel est loin d'être optimal,
tant pour les facteurs humains que pour l'apparence.
Je crois qu'elle a dit que cela ressemblait à un revolver. Un tas de gens n'aiment pas les armes.
(Rires)
Impliquer une société ayant connu des succès
dans l'ingénierie des facteurs humains et la conception industrielle
pour optimiser la conception du premier dispositif portable SMT
qui sera vendu aux patients ayant des migraines.
Et ça, c'est le second vœu.
(Applaudissements)
Et, du prix de 100.000 dollars que TED m'a octroyé si généreusement,
je donne 50.000 dollars aux gens de NeuroPace
pour se lancer dans le traitement des TOC, troubles obsessionnels compulsifs,
et je mets 50.000 autres dollars à la disposition d'une société
afin d'optimiser la conception du dispositif contre les migraines.
C'est comme ça que je compte utiliser les 100.000 dollars du prix.
(Applaudissements)
Le troisième et dernier vœu est comme qui dirait --
malheureusement, beaucoup plus compliqué car il implique les juristes.
(Rires)
Les litiges liés aux erreurs médicales aux Etats-Unis
ont augmenté le coût des assurances de responsabilité professionnelle,
de telle manière que les médecins abandonnent leur métier.
Les juristes prennent des affaires dans l'espoir d'un gros bénéfice
d'une décision importante d'un jury compatissant parce que le patient est mort tragiquement.
Le coût élevé de la santé aux Etats-Unis est partiellement dû aux coûts d'assurance et de justice.
J'ai vu des photos, des graphiques, dans le "USA Today" d'aujourd'hui
montrant que ça monte en flèche, sans maîtrise, et ceci est un facteur.
Comment la communauté TED peut-elle améliorer la situation ?
J'ai quelques idées pour démarrer.
Comme point de départ de la discussion avec le groupe TED,
une partie essentielle du problème est la nature du document écrit
du consentement éclairé que le patient ou l'épouse doit lire et signer.
A titre d'exemple, j'ai demandé aux gens qui s'occupent d'épilepsie
ce qu'ils utilisent comme consentement éclairé.
Imaginez, 12 pages, interligne simple,
que le patient doit lire avant qu'ils n'essaient de guérir l'épilepsie.
Que pensez-vous qu'on a après avoir lu 12 pages en interligne simple ?
Ils n'y comprennent goutte.
(Rires)
C'est le système actuel. Et si on faisait une vidéo ?
Nous avons des gens du spectacle ici,
il y a des gens qui savent comment faire des vidéos,
avec des présentations visuelles de l'anatomie et des fonctionnements animés.
Tout le monde sait qu'on peut faire mieux avec des images
qui seraient interactives avec le patient, où ils regardent la vidéo
et sont filmés et appuient sur "comprenez-vous ceci ? Non, je ne comprends pas."
Alors, expliquons plus simplement.
Alors, il y a une explication plus simple et "Oh Oui, je comprends ça"
Appuyez sur le bouton et c'est enregistré, que vous comprenez.
C'est une des idées.
De plus une vidéo est faite avec le patient ou l'épouse et le présentateur médical,
avec le patient qui confirme qu'il a compris les modalités de l'opération,
y compris tous les risques d'échec.
Le patient ou l'épouse accepte de ne pas intenter de procès
si l'un des risques connus se réalise.
En fait aux Etats-Unis, vous ne pouvez pas renoncer à votre droit de faire un procès.
Néanmoins, si la vidéo est là et que tout vous a été expliqué,
et que vous avez tout dans l'enregistrement vidéo,
il y a peu de chances qu'un ténor du barreau
défende ce cas parce que ce n'est plus vraiment une bonne affaire.
Si une erreur médicale survient, le patient ou l'épouse accepteront une transaction
pour une compensation par arbitrage plutôt que d'aller en justice.
Cela économiserait des centaines de millions de dollars en frais de justice aux Etats-Unis.
Et diminuerait le coût de la médecine pour tout le monde.
C'est juste un point de départ.
Et ainsi, c'est la fin de tous mes vœux.
J'aimerais avoir d'autres vœux mais trois, c'est tout ce que j'ai et les voilà.
(Applaudissements)